as your application's growing complexity
how do you harness and drive new
insights from all the chaos and is
observability just a buzzword or is it
something that you actually need to
think about spoiler alert it is my name
is Sai venom and I'm with the IBM cloud
team and today I'm joined with a special
guest hi there I'm Laura santamaría and
I am a developer advocate with log DNA
if you don't know log DNA is a core part
of our observability story on IBM cloud
but today we're gonna be talking about
observability so let's start with the
definition so observability is a
property of your systems that helps you
understand what's going on with them
monitor what they're doing and be able
to get the information you need to
troubleshoot so the way we see it
there's three major tears of
observability let's go through those now
we're gonna start out with my favorite
which is logging in addition to logging
we additionally have metrics so that's
just all of your analytics around all of
the data that you're gathering and
finally we've got monitoring now
monitoring is essentially putting up a
magnifying glass to your systems and
getting new insights from what's
actually running there today we're gonna
be starting with an example in the
bottom left corner we have sketched out
a few of the different infrastructure
pieces that we'll start with today
can we explain what those are sure we
have a public cloud can be any of them
and then you have on-prem and then let's
say we actually have some user data
maybe this is a tablet or a cell phone
so all of those infrastructure pieces
are creating and generating data and
what I'm kind of going to focus on here
is the personas that are going to
consume them so we've got that dead
persona
we've got hops
and finally we have security so all of
this data flowing in kind of a lot I
want to have some way of filtering it
down for my specific user personas to be
able to understand it so let's start
with developers
what do developers care about I actually
want to back up here for a moment though
because let's talk about all the
different levels that logging can come
from so we have three different levels
that we can think about so you have your
operating system you have kubernetes or
any other type of platform so I'm
picking kubernetes that's my favorite
and then finally your application so
your operating system in kubernetes all
send really good logs and you can use a
lot of that data pretty much as this or
add in some of your own but applications
is really where you need to spend some
time so you're devs need to create a
proper event stream and this really goes
by the garbage in garbage out system
where you really need to put in good
work and get some good data on the side
of the application so that you get good
logs out right exactly so the great
developers out there on kubernetes and
the operating systems they've
instrumented their platforms but the
application that's up to you as a
developer to make sure the
instrumentation is in place absolutely
and when you think about it let's say
that we have an operating system here
and I'm gonna say that's an operating
system and then we have kubernetes
running on it and then you actually have
your app running on top of kubernetes
and all of these are each sending data
so we have three different levels of
data all coming out and trying to come
towards the dev that wants some
information right so it looks like
they're all coming into this central
area here that's right we can talk about
this is our aggregator
so our aggregator takes in all of this
data and puts it all into one place so
we can work with it that's right but
kind of
coming back to the the problem here a
developer might not care about all of
the information flowing in how do we
drive just the pieces that they care
about like we mentioned maybe they
instrumented their specific application
how do we drive that to them absolutely
so an aggregator often has filters so in
this case let's say the dev is just
asking for data about debugging and just
some information there and your data
your filter can actually set up a
dashboard or some other way of accessing
all of that data that the dev can take a
look at just the pieces that they need
that's a core part of a observability
solution this aggregator not only does
it collect the data but it needs to
externalize it expose it so my
developers can access it and drive new
insights so we let's say we solved that
part of the puzzle
what do is care about what are the
operations teams what are they looking
for out of these systems so an
Operations team might need to know more
about degradation of its system or if a
pod is falling over maybe your database
filled up and you need to know more
information about how you can fix it the
ops teams is going to be getting data
from all of these different systems and
filtering it out to yet another
dashboard or another interface of some
sort and getting that data just what
they need right so potentially they may
not care as much about specific
application level logs but they'll be
looking to kubernetes to say hey what
was the CPU usage do we need to set up
some horizontal pod auto scalars to make
sure that we don't hit those limits
finally kind of probably see where I'm
going here with the last piece of the
puzzle with security they probably have
a dashboard that's created for them as
well so a security team let's say
they're using a third-party tool as most
security teams generally do they
identify a threat ID or maybe a customer
ID and they want to dive in deeper to a
potential threat that's been identified
so they put that information in the
aggregator and they can identify and
make kind of sense of all the chaos to
identify exactly what that specific
security analyst might be looking for
but I want to pose an interesting
question here it's not always about
going to the system and identifying
what's there
many times security advisors need to
know what's happening the second it
happens and they can't just sit there
and stare at logs all day right
absolutely this is where monitoring
comes in this is really a two-way street
we have automated alerts that can go out
and tell all of these different groups
about specific things that they're
interested specific events that they
want to know about so let's say that you
have a system that's been accessed and
it's not supposed to be frankly that
system is going to figure it out long
before a human is and that's what an
alert is for an ops team doesn't want to
find out that there is a degradation of
service when their user does they need
to know ahead of time so a good
observability solution should have the
ability to externalize the data and then
additionally set up a learning on top of
that so our dev team may be their most
comfortable and slack so they set up a
chat bot so that particular exceptions
when they're thrown they're able to know
when they happen your ops team maybe
they are using something like a paging
system so that you know in the middle of
the night if something goes down they
get alert and they can start looking
into it right away and then finally for
our security teams kind of as I
mentioned they're generally using you
know maybe third party tools or custom
dashboards they can set up custom
alerting so they can know exactly when
something goes down and to be honest
this is your new norm you're going to
have multiple clouds you're going to
have on-premise systems you're going to
have data coming directly in from your
users you need to be able to understand
what's going on and really this is what
observability is all about thanks for
joining us for this quick overview of
observability also thank you so much for
joining us today Laura absolutely my
pleasure if you have any questions
please drop us a line below if you want
to see more videos like this in the
future please like and subscribe and
don't forget you can always get started
on the cloud at no cost by signing up
for a free IP em cloud account